Korea versus China these two regions
have faced off countless times on the
rift but the results have been extremely
entertaining every single time so let's
take a look back at some of the very
best plays between the two at worlds
starting with shibez 1v3 outplay against
the IG kill in a 3d one situation to run
out now in pursuit it's gonna be
illusion but they completely back off
with that pressure in the top table a
how they get caught up with the team as
they're in fact trying to go very deep
whoa very nice hit up on God like he's
forced them flash it and they can't get
the damage down impact is somehow still
running around the line he just jumps
away good Lane and we have to consider
Dave no no it's a Gangnam they didn't
give him time to blink right back on and
SKT is now on a mission and they are
starting to excel he is no phony Lord
that was more damage than he expected
hit with everything and anything the
turret goes down this is just after kill
Loveland's out of the fight with a
passive down they continue on the man
down below big parma now gonna go down
if it's one thing that means it's going
to be two three or even four things four
asses from OMG and cool the max range
charm the lock up the knocks out the
takedown
bengi gets to kill they're not going to
wait to close the exhaust is there but
it's not going to be enough they're
gonna fall one after the other in the I
think I can do
but I think I can they really can SKT
can they're going three turns in a row
and another kill I stopped at four and
five they're going for six seven eight
inhibitor turned at 12 minutes OMG could
lose their first game here Zak's still
not joining the fight he does not want
part of this everyone who's walked over
there has died no diamond on Cohen in
the Midlands and these are the frame
dead from that Mary's in sake though
what sonido surely will be able to
finish up for is actually just flash on
towards him you can see as you mentioned
the team cups and it's a time in a 3d
one I have to see some more information
so far Jace is staying top we don't have
the vision toggle just yet there he is
or does have flash does he use it as a
round car gonna go for the 1v2 plenty of
damage to the rockers leave the trade
sit back he bumps over the minions side
steps a deadly flourish emmalegs Gees
looking for the kill
sonic wave connects resonating strike
dude might just survive
they didn't know where the lee sin is so
they don't go for the play
now maybe on Tallulah was in trouble
cookers but he canceled the slicing
Belgium this so much SPG's team play is
top-notch
but this insane wombo combo from the
2017 worlds group stage is simply
something to admire
[Applause]
all the vision inside of Edie's jungle
ice although a boss as well married to
dive into the table and their first kill
coming straight down
Danny will work of clear up inside of
the Catholicism
it will give input kill they gonna take
those are may as well this is a
whitewash it's a massacre but arrived at
we get the back
they have the explosive damage
go name surrounded Emma Baker without a
flash without a prayer
Hey yes respect Baker's like here's the
it's gonna be two already and in the
back leg oh let me cannot kill up won't
those be Chinese members are falling
left and right is he on the run he not
here to follow soon jumps for finds the
tough to flash away but if the 3v5 can
you win this fight and make it down to
two and what fight is all it took for
the Twitter
[Applause]
crowd laughs John the pump a look bought
over then drank again I take a look at
the mug to to buy some time Public Radio
that will keep on your life the few
seconds longer but ambition sticks
around on the frontline cop is bouncing
the malefic visions harder to target and
Cupid gets atop a double kill kicking
off our list of solo kills is this
historic 1v1 between star Warren Royal
Club scorn and Samsung white spawn
cloudtemplar these believe the force
right now is truly game azúcar prophecy
so free Wow who's going down very low
gear this man is just about the same but
the HP is not magic shield are trying to
farm their way through it I'll do this
on Yoda won't sit up to the McHale don't
know to run and jay-z's only gonna roll
the Mesa don't think is defensively
enough he's gonna pull it through one
more it should do it the pop goes
through ignite is running that's the
count can't get away though or what's
how it too many Oh take down that's
gonna be Cola he gets chucked out go
there to paused outside of the mid lane
either beautiful
did he get that beautiful play by corn
to make it a one for one of the midlane
pretty beneficial for him in this game
but honestly it's about corn staying
safe him it's a little dangerous for him
to open up he actually opened up as if
he had back up court decided not to turn
he realizes the bat resistance has been
built clearlove oh now a buzzes if it's
a wall a wall but it's gonna be now
ain't going down can he get away takes
our hits doesn't buddy's know in France
is this to be one FC ZF first possibly
no Philip he's gonna drop in there dot
these out of the bubble there's one busy
path to the second note then there's
porn our top lane right now bit later it
also goes down the flashing gate from
Baker and it's the room prison in it all
the spells all of the time faker the 1v1
against born you have tanks on SKT you
have no tanks on aren't you give some
credit to oranjee they steal away that
cloud rake uncontested youth is about
cigar out throws looper against the wall
stuns him with the wallop crunches down
looks for more one last thought oh no
harm no foul they walk right back out of
this with a flat board he's gone for the
big flat bar attack
[Applause]
right now Cupid's gonna be under further
pressure escorts up for she a slice
available buy some time the found the
hip pointer birthday coupons catcher
she 2013's grand final between royal and
SKT
had a ton of incredible turnaround but
this last-second save by impact was so
incredible even White's couldn't believe
it on this one tries to get in with Zyra
he made with itself or the water believe
it yeah I think we're gonna see a hard
engage from world very quickly
straightaway crescendo coming down
equalizer gonna follow impact actually
take a very low but look at that the
turnaround damage from SKT looks like
they're gonna continue under the term
bengi is the one tanking if he gets out
on a safe safeguard if you will lose all
rights I kill though take it from white
they continue in a poohmandu piglet now
in the eyes of royal the Jaycees strong
pink this is gonna get caught out but
look at this so do you think that gets
away and that's learning to be whites in
trouble just as they can chase SK
Telecom a back in control these fights
are decided by inches right now don't
call our this stage cornea actually
gonna dime tall zero damage to kill him
up the fish is already events to report
cleanup
[Music]
comes Emma let's Gino CC to speak up to
us get the chaplain Corps JJ the flashy
love really once endo candy get the
attacks gonna go for the peanut still
alive somehow but scouts there with a
vengeance now on to curl they go the
roots gonna land a look up for shots
should do it but he's taking up freeway
as this thought he might kill a flare
love but no now he's in the danger zone
this could be enough and now it's still
gonna be the one picked up nicely played
by Kurt away damage across on this one
poor are going to lose his life as well
interrupted it blank hanging around the
mid lane along the way I'm going on this
could be the fight sausage is sighs
stiff shall we could be the target for
the void never grasp is caught cocoon as
well slicing Maelstrom I skate ear on
the board they trade one for one go
under the bot lane and here comes that
slinky does have the old
here it comes and of course the dance
would have been used flat stuck at the
end up heaps leave it here comes the
chase down and there's not a lot of ways
out him let's G getting low go to be
careful the knock of is it for Baker
make it number two the blue brake not
gonna land it comes back but it doesn't
matter a shutdown for the but player in
the world hoping to bring one more for
SKT is blank now finds an easy search
woulda kill the beer not gonna matter
Blanc gets himself a solo this goes like
a thanks Rene and mystique are available
party San Jose for the explosive charge
[Applause]
there's been so many great team fights
between Korea and China at Worlds but
we're kicking off our list with this
super bloody fight between star horn
Royal Club and Samsung white from 2014
all by dandy you don't think he's gonna
do anything with it yes err wait for
insect he comes in the level 6 is
actually used to trying it out dandy may
have bitten off more than he can chew on
this one he's forced to get out Dumbo
don't want to get the red buff over
there's the teleport there's the red
carpet laid out but its front foot goes
over to Z to get the second one for Cola
insect will fall blonde coming in price
get tail and on the end
he's gonna try and get that cut broke
down and he does get a good cut back and
hoozy but it's going to be gored can he
start to clean things up they continue
the fight a very low from this one loop
role so girl oh that scared the cola
will go down
oh great arcane shift it leaves out
shall we there by yourself if accused of
abilities but they trade what's the one
again TDP community use dude coming it's
a good shot by cloudtemplar focusing on
two Nocturne and it looks like this
bikes heavily showing in favor of azubu
bronze know the term around they catch
up flat Amir in taxes double kill as
they chase down bad life I don't think
he's going to be able to make it out
they do have to proc from the fades on
strike force and the triple pill
poor kid Tommy's got a pretty good item
pill to start shredding in here the
colon goes out to star core Oh again in
the front when they were now over a
stall at this time and the fight
continues just blow Baron they got it
anything better place it along here bike
rack down
they get quite hurt he tries to jump
back to his be base hit tie coming up
darling bad jobs outfalls is right there
as well the one-for-one coming out and
it looks like they will continue
pressure on the site a double-kill
coming up top for his eye as he puts
himself in the middle using going down
as well and they're continuously
fighting this one the juggle
I think that's hurting them a little bit
the vision is back and forth the night
and it comes out very Jing in the side
of his you defrock kids looking to
finish off one became a great arcane
shift out of the Gatling siege onto this
turret but Royal does have a bit better
sear it is off this time is the
crescendo goes out and lucky goes in
crescendo and equalize the landing but
pickman's still alive in the back that
looking will go down to shobhraj does
not matter do a cover keeping the
pressure on SKT no running away from all
they keep going in got legs down the
pray the flames winner is shut off
they're coming in by Baker they're
looking for the cooldowns
but they're in the middle of the fight
get it torn apart that kick back put the
hip to the face before he gets away good
like he's gonna get go down the kick
comes in here Mike's gonna follow him
through Cola gets kicked back into him
he's gonna get crannies gonna get
dropped down equalizer was down in time
Oh
who's he gets caught out he's in trouble
looks like who's he may make it out he
burns the class get to know us we put on
the barrier no is back it's the leap
strike they take him down though his way
it's coming from the back and lucky
tries to end up the percent away this
time
Wise's I know it's at the trouble but
the zonda services 20 planes can he get
out both Muslims out no hate min is dead
Tommy's in trouble he's gonna go down
big nice tanky down and turn it let's
look at big look he's just he knows ups
of troubles I want to do one
I give a triple kill sipping tea company
clothes who's he gonna go for he's
trying to get co2 the but boozy though
is left to learn the bright side they
need to keep you in check zero go slow
if take a heart beat me they still
applause dancing around in this worth
that to kill over to Samsung were these
my routines do that there is Uzi to get
the door will jump away to stay away
he comes in Baker he's gonna get stand
up teleports from both top plane is
coming in as well
fades calls already down the Fox in a
fantastic position EDT losing so much
out there that dog from barn
damn still alive at the moment is
amazing day with a beat double kill now
top line gets dunked at the same time
and banks just hopping everywhere
absolutely amazing fight SK Telecom t1
with the A's admission on the one side
the rest the team on the other looking
for a bit of damage shadow gonna pop the
qss here comes Jimmy to decline it's
several stop the rule is already got a
one-hit sponsor he might burn down he's
gonna get him actually that's you
already know who's he caught up
exhausted in Ted three make that four
four one two Samsung here last few
little bit care of yours coming in in
rouen they don't quite dedicate
themselves to knock in the turret down
naka comes through on to three how much
more is the rear here grabs smeb and P
Turner here a late teleport for four oh
there's a 5e for momentarily when the
kickback doesn't lay in the roof now
make a good run I help voice of y plus D
club get a little bit boring gorilla
running down but no he eats a trap
give me more
doesn't wake it up and looking on the
kilt bread for game against three two
one this now
maybe a little for coming through spent
Watson gets healed up a little bit more
and now getting barbecue to the backside
takes the harpoon to the back and a
stipend out to scout drops i boy stands
alone mister in said jersey wunderbar
blow the engage give it a crime spell
year comes to spray-and-pray labor cups
pork tails wanaka to knock back to their
mega swallowed all righty now easy a bit
isolated failure to change with the
theft last four here comes the dive out
of duty
they have the first they mysteriously
try to make him down to the dude shut
almost half the damage put some of the
trade of that look she's already dead
walk towards the jump away the deadly
venom may be taken down let the other
chases wild banker going towards the
turret fine shout over the damaged
[Applause]
we're brown charges up that your end
shield doesn't fire the trigger few days
about to get excited
the cosmic rays despite some time
the safety he gets into the world
triple kill picked up through the fence
blast away to safety now she is the
target
Rula not gonna find the Quadra kill as
crowd takes him down watch is impossible
baron steel against OMG from the 2014
World Championship kick off our list of
the best pit plays the Baron is it going
to go that way that's the question
coming around the side guerrilla tries
to come in watch his back
[Applause]
buzu boots and it looks like they're out
of the fight oh wow
somebody's wife children apartment
amazing J's gonna have to join the team
I think there's the old zn4 wolf TPN but
town gods of the part network gaming 2-0
to start for now clean look is attack
that's a trade kill back in pond now
stuck on top of the dragon faker gets
his pers kill the game and still trades
back and forth but EDG are routed the
three dead so far the tongue it's
heeey
gets more kills and they get the dragon
really good opportunity for them
weightless too long this baron is gonna
take too much damage the Oilers have to
get it pretty much
[Applause]
wagons life the flesh more crows
[Applause]
applause the best death brushes
towerdive and level one invades are all
up next in our list of the best set
place between Korea and China at Worlds
and they go in they get to see the gun a
rapid start another gun free from kid
Oh what they knew they had impact back
Boris to flash you don't take that
Russia's can in the level one it looks
like he's gonna be going down very
fastest on there and it looks like they
may be able to continue benke trying to
help this would be a double buff trail
he follows the sonic wave and he gets
the safeguard out as well takes that
jump first rocket jump destroy to beat
out rod goes in she gets knocked up that
roosters
I've done yet expect the unexpected
put down they still want to go for this
fight pawn fires a shock blast without
the gate over the wall Cola is it a
whole heap of trouble this is really bad
from the Midlands
early
these glasses away
the time three men go will they get
their two kills on something like the
tristana it's shoot away with the rope
with holes and jump away miss also she
stands safety he's won on once again oh
god team fights a desert early 100mg
tried to collapse but instead in samsung
group and come around on towards then
Dada 777th how are they gonna be balls
divides away that it may well be he's
gone we're just stop around it flash
it's dead baby's gonna be a binding from
safe we'll see how they go in they're
gonna start setting up it's gonna be an
invade any second one forty eight keep
your eye on the clock neither of them
can see each other and they'll push it
catch him doing this with low mana know
how its own fiora's missing walks into
the camp actually gets away from the
skill shot but doesn't really matter
smites for a buddy healing trying to run
out one more hey don't do it that's
first one mate again they can sneak deft
into this brush there but the rocks of
all time here with rice this is a bit of
a 2 vs. 3 - they have the damage on
smash one more shot of doing this switch
back of the girl they get one now how's
the trick gonna work
they're been gentle rose gold games be
plus 200 for Rox Tigers they are ladies
better as a team
but the reading gauge that gorilla means
nothing to us subtly peanut is here on
the Olaf a flash force an item I love
but he is still chasing on the deaf
who's nearly out of HP the chase hombre
first blood to for Peter they might be a
third and their rien gate for Goro what
can he do much of anything it doesn't
seem like a lot peanut very very low
fences don't you dare go for my team
base it's a lot to ask for here comes
Blanco Finlay that taught him confirms
the knock of this could be enough damage
let's bounce bring them right and
observe them knock back there it's all
perfect
if you got something happen it's all
depends if W wants to sit the picked up
by Rula aunty she gave the latest of
wealth 2017 thanks for watching if you
want more great content be sure to hit
that subscribe button
[Music]